there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry world upon world entire
civilizations far more than we ever
theorized it's okay
passing through we stake now claim
there
I thought I was gone but that energy
from your hands how did you do that
I'm not the same woman I was 30 years
ago Henry this place it changes you
an adaptation is part of it but some of
it is evolution they good it's ready to
ascend let's go see our daughter
welcome back everyone it's Charlie you
probably just saw that Marvel confirmed
ant-man and the wasp 3 is happening
there are a lot of big plot threads
after Avengers endgame with the quantum realm quantum energy and ant-man and the wasp
with the way they used quantum
energy that they still have to address
as that scene implies Janet Van Dyne is
now an involved being like you would
think of a mutant or an x-men character
in the MCU there's also a lot of young
Avengers time-travel stuff that they're
setting up through avengers endgame I'm
still doing the Avengers infinity saga a
giant box set giveaway all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your best theory about how they'll
use the quantum realm and quantum energy in future movies so we just break this
down top-5 style careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen Avengers endgame or
ant-man the wasp but I feel like most of
you have probably seen those movies by
now number 5 as I said they confirmed
that they're doing ant-man 3 they
haven't confirmed what the title is a
lot of us are just calling it ant-man
the wasp in stature because Cassie Lange is still a teenager right now as of the
end of Avengers endgame but Peyton Reed is coming back to direct again making
him one of the first Marvel directors to
do an entire trilogy of movies himself
next to James Gunn
but guardians of the galaxy 3 won't
happen till 2023 I will explain the
release dates for everything in a second
too but a lot of people after the Marvel
phase for comic-con panel asked if they
would do another ant-man movie because
they have so much new IP because of
Fantastic Four Deadpool the main x-men
films in terms of box office ant-man has
always been one of their smaller
franchises just post all your size puns
in the comments both of the ant-man
movies have been great but just in terms
of actual box office profits they don't
make quite as much money as some of
their other IP and it just seems like a
new x-men movie new Fantastic Four a new
Deadpool might earn way more money than
an ant-man movie so Paul Rudd was making
all kinds of jokes after they announced
their phase 4 slate about them not doing
ant-man 3 I think just to get people
worked up so they will start yelling at
Marvel to make a third film but number
four the reason why they need to do
ant-man 3 is because there are too many
cliffhangers involving the quantum realm
and quantum energy that they have to
answer as of the end of Avengers endgame
we know they perfected time-travel using
it and also as part of endgame
time-travel we learned that they can
also use it to travel between dimensions
realities or universes in
multiverse technically all those things
aren't the same thing but you get the
idea they can use it to phase across the
multiverse and because of Janet Van Dyne 'he's evolved body we know that quantum
energy has a lot of biological
properties you could even call them
mutant like abilities that they haven't
totally explained yet because they made
that movie before the Fox Disney deal
closed ant-man and the wasp so that's
why she talked about it as being evolved
she couldn't say the word mutant Janet
Van Dyne just lays her hands on the
ghost stabilizes her quantum states so
she stops phasing between universes
uncontrollably but that's it they didn't
explain how that works or what was
happening exactly they're just leaving
that for the third movie so this is one
of the reasons why they're doing ant-man
3 before they announced their marvel
x-men reboot they keep saying that
that's a little ways off because there
are a couple big concepts that they have
to explain and as the name implies
Doctor Strange - and the multiverse of
madness you also get the teaser at
Avengers in game in the first Doctor
Strange movie of the concept of multiple
realities ant-man 3 and Doctor Strange -
we'll just explain those ideas in much
greater detail and use them as much
bigger story devices although obviously
Doctor Strange - is going to lean more
heavily on the multiverse side of things
in ant-man 3 we'll just focus more on
the actual quantum realm of it all that
includes number three the very
noticeable quantum city in the
background is Hank Pym and Janet Van
Dyne are leaving during the ant-man the
wasp I love how they don't even mention
it like Hank Pym couldn't be bothered
because he's seeing his wife for the
first time in over 20 years Janet Van
Dyne just thinking about seeing her
daughter hope again but the real reason
why nobody mentions the quantum city in
the movie is because they were just
leaving it for the third film to explain
oh yeah there's a whole city full of
beings down there they're all highly
evolved just like me Marvel has made
some changes to the quantum realm from
the comics in the comics it was actually
called the Microverse and it was
populated by a race of beings called the
micronauts they have their own wars
their own Society they look kind of like
transformers but the reason why Marvel
can't use the name Microverse or
micronauts is because that's owned by
Hasbro Marvel just license them when
they made the original comic book so
many years ago all with interchangeable
parts so your child can create dozens of
different
and when micronauts start a child's
imagination working he can create just
about anything toys that climb toys that
spin toys that float toys that stimulate
yon mind but the basic concept is still
there you have a race of humanoid
quantum beings living in the quantum
city and maybe other comic book
characters that have the technology in
the science to enter the quantum realm
there's no way that hank pam is the
first person in the history of the
multiverse who's been smart enough to
figure out the quantum realm he's just
one of the only people on our version of
Earth in the multiverse that's figured
it out the whole concept of the quantum
realm is that it's a sub layer of
reality connecting all the different
universes of the multiverse there are
infinite universes in the multiverse but
there's only one quantum realm
connecting them all that's why the
Avengers can use it to travel between
realities like Captain America hopping
back to our reality after living out his
life with this version of Peggy Carter
and it's the reason why Ghost phase is
uncontrollably between universes until
Janet Van Dyne gives her a dose of
quantum energy to stabilize her at least
part of the movie is going to be
dedicated to explaining who those people
are down there and whether or not their
friend or foe there's also the people
that sonny birch talks about that he
works for people that don't take no for
an answer there's all kinds of
speculation about how Marvel could tie
that to Norman Osborn in Oscorp there
aren't that many people on planet earth
with the amount of money that Sonny
Birch's talking about in organizations
that powerful but we've already talked
about setting up the concept of x-men in
the MCU number two this is where you
also start to get into Young Avengers
Cassie Lang stature King the conquer and
more overt time-travel stories Marvel
and Kevin Feige have only said that
they're working on a young avengers
project they didn't say if it be a movie
or another Disney Plus series but they
have Cassie Lang stature already Cherie
the Miss Marvel she-hulk and Kate Bishop
Hawkeye characters coming soon you can kind of include Morgan Stark when she's
a little bit older if Young Avengers is
going to be a time-travel franchise it's
easier to explain that an older version
of her from the future could join the
team at some point and if you want to
get technical you can't include
spider-man on that team because it's
still so young an age but really I
counted more as a full-blown regular
Avengers team member because of the
events of Avengers infinity war where
Ironman
made it official kid Avengers spider-man
appearing in a Young Avengers project
would also depend on Marvel and Sony
renewing their sharing deal again after
the next two Spider Man appearances they will but they're probably not going to
talk about that publicly until they
absolutely have to which is minimum
three to four years but number one
really important details release date
and characters so right now Marvel has
three movies dated for 2022 there's an
untitled Marvel movie dated February
18th they've already confirmed Black
Panther 2 is May 6th and then the third
film is another untitled Marvel movie
dated July 29th Michael Douglas just
confirmed that they start filming
ant-man 3 February 2021
meaning that ant-man 3 is probably going to
take that February 2022 date but get
hyped up about this the current leading
rumor is that Fantastic Four is going to
be that July 2022 movie meaning that
they would have to announce it and start
casting it and start filming it by
summer 2021 I'll do more videos about
what's going on with Marvel phase 4 when
we get more details but leave all your
video requests in the comments below
there's also a bunch of stuff starting
in the next couple of weeks as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see the videos when I post
them everybody click here for my new
spider-man into the spider verse 2
teaser trailer and click here for that
New Avengers 5 announcement thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!